[Music]
ploud IOT core is a fully managed
service that allows you to easily and
securely connect manage and ingest data
from millions of globally dispersed
devices cloud IOT core in combination
with other services on Google cloud IOT
platform provides a complete solution
for collecting processing analyzing and
visualizing IOT data in real time to
support improved operational efficiency
device telemetry data is forwarded to a
cloud pub/sub topic which can then be
used to trigger cloud functions you can
also perform streaming analysis with
cloud dataflow or custom analysis with
your own subscribers this diagram
summarizes the service components in the
flow of data this hands-on lab shows you
how to use Google cloud platform console
to create a cloud IOT core device
registry and how to register a device it
also shows you how to run a sample to
connect a device and publish device
telemetry events you're just one lab
away from completing your quest and
getting your badge in case you haven't
been following our other videos a quest
is a series of related labs that form a
learning path on quick labs completing
this quest earns you this badge to
recognize your achievement next up on
our quest is compute engine QuickStart
windows
[Music]